[Music]
right come on let's be honest ramen is
that comfort food that we all love
especially on a cold day and
if you're studying at university but
today trust me i'm going to show you how
to elevate that notoriously cheap dish
into something delicious and guess what
give me a v that's right vegetarian
right come in oscar let me show you the
ingredients uh egg noodles uh delicious
rehydrated liter in like three three and
a half minutes beautiful seaweed
scallions tofu
ginger
and cauliflower and these here these are
the secret ingredient these are
the dried shiitake mushrooms they're
gonna go into the water and they're
gonna rehydrate now traditionally you
can start this with a chicken stock a
vegetable stock or just plain water
today we're going to start with plain
water i'm going to show you how to
elevate this ramen
right let's have 10 minutes on the clark
so we can start off with boiling water
first of all season that water okay
nicely now in the next pan i've got a
rolling water we're gonna put our eggs
in there get them on a spoon and drop
them into that water okay
please time me six minutes
justin
bring it out to the ball
don't ball them ferociously they'll get
that sort of black line around the
outside ball them gently and i want to
ball that but a little bit of sort of
yolky bit in the middle mushrooms into
the water immediately okay
in
and this is where it starts to sort of
go up a level
turn the gas up
okay and now we're going to start
creating that base
first off
a tablespoon of mixture paste in
okay and give that a really good mix now
those mushrooms are doubling in size
okay and the exciting thing now is that
they're starting to give flavor to that
water
from there
a nice tablespoon of soy
okay that's going to give some sort of
richness to the broth okay a little bit
of acidity a touch of mirin okay that
gives it a little bit of lift and a bit
of a bite
and then
one of my favorites tawarashi spice
beautiful japanese pepper in now bring
that up to the boil
lightly season it with the chili flakes
get your egg noodles in okay
and then from there
turn off the gas okay
that's right turn off the gas
now give that a good mix
taste
that broth
that's delicious touch more salt
okay for me
and then
a little bit of salt
and look
the seaweed
scissors
i just cut up some really nice strands
of seaweed let's have to be very careful
with the salt in the beginning
i like nice long sort of almost strips
like julienne
okay every minute this broth is getting
better
tastier and deeper if i was going
straight vegetarian of course i'll be
using a vegetable stock a chicken stock
it's delicious that bee stock equally is
delicious but now open up those egg
noodles okay and then just taste again
good now it's nearly there
tofu
don't
slice this
too thinly okay
just literally
into nice long
beautiful strands
lift it up
and just place that on top
the secret now is that we're not going
to be boiling that stock
but
all those ingredients from the mirin
to the miso are almost starting
to sort of
marinate
oscar please pan down have a quick look
now you can see look
it's almost like this smorgasbord of
delicious ingredients and
man that's good
that's so good take that off and let it
sit there and simmer
i want to say simmer i mean put the lid
back on
take your sesame oil and just gently hit
the surface with that but make sure the
gas is off
i want a touch more spice in there for
me just a touch
let it simmer the gas is off okay eggs
are boiling
time please
three minutes down
right three minutes down cauliflower
open your palm flat side down and then
grate
now
this gives a bit of texture to the ramen
it's a great way
of adding crunch to the top
especially with those eggs
and then from there look
i'm almost sort of
getting all the way down
to the
actual
these bits here
just cut round there okay
and just slice those bits nice and thin
and these stalks
are so delicious
okay like the stalks on a
broccoli open up that beautiful
ramen and put those stalks in there
again another layer of flavor
now from there
take your cauliflower
put that into the bowl
okay
lightly season it
salt and pepper and then lightly dust
that with some rice flour
now that's going to give a little bit of
crunch and texture to the cauliflower so
when we fry it it's almost gonna be like
this beautiful crispy fried cauliflower
i want some chili in there so i've got
some heat okay
and then look
a touch more rice flour
that helps to give it a coating
and it's almost like a sort of a nice
little shallow fly
hot pan
get the oil in
and then watch i want to sort of get
that really nice crispy texture that
sits on top
of those noodles it's a shallow fry okay
in there
halfway five minutes down now get that
all up to temp
touch more salt in there
whilst that oil is waiting no it's gonna
be there
check it first and then look
just literally
sprinkle that in there and look what's
happening to my cauliflower
it's getting really nice and crispy
now again
i love frying in a non-stick pan because
i get that texture and
i really get it nice and crispy i'm not
using that much oil
okay it's a light shallow fry but look
look at the color of that cauliflower
beautiful now it's going golden brown
and that's the texture that i want
on top of this delicious ramen
it's amazing just a simple vegetable
like cauliflower can enhance a beautiful
ramen from there
take a little slice
of kitchen towel get that ready
and then look
it's like it's really nice and crispy
i've got a bit of chili in there as well
rice flour starts to coat the
cauliflower it almost protects it and
gives it this sort of jacket
that allows it to get nice and crispy
time please
three minutes
right seven minutes in and look drain
that off
and you can see that beautiful
crispy
incredible cauliflower there that's so
good
so good
another season
beautiful now
how do we build up those layers okay
i've got some wonderful
spring onions
and i like to slice them a little bit
thicker and longer
on the bias so i go sideways this time
okay i'm saving the nice sort of tops
for
the garnish and the sort of white parts
again i'm just gonna sprinkle in
over that oh man
that is just like a beautiful fragrant
smell so tops go on top
i've got my ginger
sitting alongside i've got my seaweed
inside
and the tofu now is sort of taking on
that stock one more final taste
and look at it in there
oscar come in come in pan down pan down
pan down please
that is so delicious oh man
now eggs take them out
i always like to sort of put them into
cold water first before i start
peeling them
and look a little trick
just get the base
crack it and set it in water
crack it
blow and sit in water and i'll show you
why in a minute right time to serve get
your bowl this is a very generous sort
of
family style dish
okay big
deep
beautiful dish
now
look at that
noodles in first
the flavor from that stock in that short
period of time
is extraordinary
90 seconds man we're up against it
look
take that out
the smell is incredible
beautiful
from there
my sort of pickled ginger
my scallions
spring onions
and then look it's beautiful
nice
crispy
cauliflower on top
amazing cauliflower now with the eggs
time please
50 seconds 50 seconds so tap tap tap
pull pull pull and then just put in your
top of your hand
and blow
and that from there
literally
should come off super quick and it is
and then literally
dip it back in the water any excess
shell and it should be slightly should
be slightly run running the middle
oh man
runny
yolky and then look just from there
just literally snip snip snip snip
some fresh cilantro coriander doesn't
matter what country you're in it's all
delicious
and there we are a beautiful ramen in
10.
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay
intent cookbook inspired by this series
and trust me you're gonna come out a
much better chef and if you like this
video don't forget to subscribe to my
amazing youtube channel for more good
luck